[Applause]
when they're talking about fixtures a
kind of laughs thing but I thought this
trait was dead and I just kind of like
sometimes you're offended like no it's
not you know I'm trying to rise it up
we're gonna bring her though I have a
phrase called turn your beaters into
heaters just a lot of people beat up the
shoes and I can make it look into like
someone fresh kicks I can make it look
brand new like wow you can actually do
this oh yeah I can put your shoes back
to life and fix your kicks that's what I
do biggest kick
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Joshua marine I'm 20 years
old and I'm a cobbler I grew up in the
north side of Chicago
born and raised going up you know I
would always look to my father's shop my
father's a cop my grandfather's a
cobbler he taught me everything that I
know I was like you know what I'm gonna
take this to another level I'm gonna
bring my sneaker culture in this and I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna go hard you
know I'm gonna do this for a living when
I started I was about if stories and I
would find shoes and I would fix him up
I'll repair him touch him up there was
one summer I found a pair 12 a pair of
Georgian 12 I bought them for like
thinking like twenty one dollars I
cleaned them up
I can't them up put new laces on them
and sold them for like around 180
laughter I got influenced into the
sneaker culture like hey you know I
could make a living off this I kept in
the shoes and I could sell them the
copper ring it's like an art form you
know people live this people are like
artists people design their own shoes a
lot of teenagers
I want this colorway I can't find it
anywhere you know can you please provide
this for me oh yeah sure you know I
could paint it up for you I can make it
look how you want them it's always a
good feeling you know make people smile
and make people pleased with you know my
work you know because I've helped them
out and they helped me out
[Music]
I feel like I to represent knowledge at
college because that's you know that's
home you know it's home this is you know
where I belong just where I have to
represent I open up three shops within a
year you know a lot of people think
that's crazy
not how did you do it you know like what
are you doing you know I'm just hustling
I get a lot of support from the
neighborhood when people come into the
shop that I know whose owner here
everybody all right you're the team
cobbler yeah that's me so it makes me
feel like home you know it makes me feel
like I belong here like you know I'm
purposeful wait for this you know this
is what I'm done for
you